climactic battles guts gore and
head-popping antics all mark an
over-the-top season of the boys and what
exactly is a herogasm this is everything
you need to know about the ending of the
boys season 3.
the boys season 3 opens with our
characters in vastly different spaces
than where season two left them yet the
celebrity of the seven remains strong as
the action-packed film dawn of the seven
opens in theaters butcher teams up with
the seven's queen maeve who wants
revenge on homelander and longs to ruin
botsworld if we can find this
weapon or
whatever it is
maybe we can use it to blow homelanders
brains out frenchie and kimiko enjoy a
blossoming romance and dream of escaping
to mursai mother's milk re-enters his
daughter janine's life and strives to
become an excellent dad however out of
all the boys huey's life has changed the
most the newly competent protagonist and
starlight have gone public with the
romance and huey co-heads the federal
bureau of superhuman affairs alongside
congresswoman victoria newman he enjoys
a tight workplace camaraderie with
newman and feels like they're
accomplishing a lot and their mission to
capture aaron's soups with the help of
government funding alas as always in the
boys universe nothing good can last huey
soon discovers that newman is actually
nadia a soup who grew up in an orphanage
for superhumans video footage from
newman's childhood home exposes her as
the head popper from season 2 and that
she's been groomed since childhood by
bought ceo stan edgar huey feels like a
weak loser once again and sets out on
his darkest path yet
annie's starlight january remains the
only known soup with entirely pure
motives starlight yearns to change the
seven from the inside until she realizes
how fruitless that mission is she sees
the psychotic nature of homelander
growing more threatening and she's
scared alas huey tells starlight she
needs to continue her tenure in the
seven until they can figure out a way to
kill the leader of the seven when
starlight and homelander attend a
meeting with stan edgar he informs them
that starlight's popularity points are
up while homelanders have plummeted this
has the unsurprising consequence that
the already threatening stance
homelander has towards starlight grows
fiercer and more ominous edgar tells
starlight that she will become the first
ever female co-captain of the seventh
she fears what homelander will do to her
and must figure out a way to harness her
newfound corporate power to take the
psychopath down before it's too late
starlight recruits new seven-member and
former boy band superstar supersonic to
help her fight homelander but has to
learn to stand tall in the face of her
mounting fears starlight's new role as
co-captain of the 7 presents many
obstacles on her season 3 journey
in the boys season 3 homelander finds
the public tides turning against him for
the first time as stormfront's nazi past
is exposed homelander is forced to
explain his relationship with her
exposing cracks in his veneer
homelander's narcissism soars in season
3 2 as he sees the weaknesses of the
other members of the 7 as a reflection
of himself he attempts to demean
starlight by demanding that she sing a
marilyn monroe style happy birthday to
him on his televised birthday special
and is incensed when she refuses
homelander hasn't dealt with rejection
before and secretly it's his greatest
fear head soup falls into a dark space
when stormfront kills herself he
realizes he didn't buy into her plan of
building a master race because he is the
master race in his mind homelander
believes he's better than anyone else
when starlight leaks a damning video of
homelander on social media he decides to
drop his good guy charade he reveals the
true disdain he holds for people and
gains fans in the worst of humanity who
feel represented by him i'm not just
like the rest of you i'm stronger i'm
smarter
i'm better homelander no longer has a
reason to hold his darkest self back
anthony starr plays homelander with a
subtle malevolence that gives the
character authentic humanity making him
truly terrifying for characters like
butcher and huey the introduction of a
24-hour temporary compound v serum
proves to be a game changer queen maeve
secretly gives a few vials of the
superhuman serum to butcher in case he
needs to use it against homelander temp
v causes a user to develop temporary
superpowers that wane within a day of
the drug's injection while the initial
high of tempe allows for superhuman
strength and other powers the
detrimental side effects are equally
strong butcher initially hesitates to
use the drug but eventually succumbs to
its lure as does huey ultimately butcher
and huey both become hooked the two
experience horrific hangovers and
personality changes after using tempe
and soon discover that prolonged use of
the drug will kill them temp v opens up
a plethora of storyline possibilities
and may play a pivotal role in future
seasons by the season's end the
prolonged negative effects of the
superhuman drug become apparent for
butcher
season three of the boys ushers in the
long-anticipated arrival of jensen
ackles as soldier boy echols play
soldier boy with sarcastic bad boy
appeal sans a good heartbeating
underneath you should smile more
i bet it's a beautiful smile once the
greatest soup in the world soldier boy
was the leader of a mega soup team
called payback the group included future
seven member black noir soldier boys
lover crimson countess and gunpowder
among others the world believes soldier
boy died in 1984 while saving the world
from nuclear annihilation the truth is
far more dark and complicated billy
butcher thinks the chemical that killed
soldier boy may be the only weapon that
can end homelander his crew attempts to
steal it from a clandestine russian lab
only to find a very much alive soldier
boy imprisoned in suspended animation
after butcher and huey take temp v they
free soldier boy and recruit him to help
them kill homelander however the team
quickly learns that soldier boy is as
psychopathic as their nemesis yet the
radioactive superhero can render another
suit powerless by blasting them with his
energy so the boys need him to take down
the seven alas mother's milk has
personal reasons to want soldier boy
dead and once again the group breaks
apart huey and butcher accompany soldier
boy as he locates his former payback
teammates the suit makes up for lost
time by ingesting hardcore drugs and
reminiscing about his heyday
season 3 of the boys may introduce us to
new characters but the corruption in the
new supes mirrors that of those we
already know through almost 40 years of
torture at the hands of the russians
soldier boy discovers that his former
payback team betrayed him in 1984 in
nicaragua the team is sent by vaught to
help new cia agent grace mallory in the
historical contra battle against the
sandinistas this is a fictionalized
version of the battle that sparked the
real world iran contra affairs scandal
involving oliver north crimson countess
the woman soldier boy once loved quickly
hatches a plan to hand soldier boy over
to the russians during the height of the
battle the entire payback team is in on
the plan and soldier boy has nearly four
decades to plot his revenge soulja boy
won't rest until he can torture and
murder his traitorous team the betrayal
by the members of payback not to mention
soldier boy's ego maniacal personality
once again proves even the best soups in
history were terrible people butcher and
huey set up crimson countess by trapping
her in the trailer where she now lives
to make her easy prey the countess seems
to have a part-time porn site where she
communicates with seth rogen in a
humorous cameo appearance the countess
is also a fierce advocate for chimps and
has released the sappy ballad chimps
don't cry in their honor you know the
chimps are physically incapable of
crying
but that doesn't mean they're not crying
on the inside the rest of the payback
team proves easy for soldier boy to
track down
in episode 6 an exclusive soup event
called hirogasm occurs and it is exactly
what the name implies an invite-only
festival of debauchery for soups
[Music]
the event hosted by the tnt twins tessa
and tommy former members of payback and
middle-aged siblings with vague powers
gives us a visual of the insane sexual
appetite supes have soldier boy hughie
and butcher head to herogasm to kill the
twins but starlight shows up with
mother's milk to stop them suffering
from ptsd soulja boy is unable to focus
his radioactive energy and ends up
killing or grievously injuring a myriad
of supes the build-up to the season 3
finale really starts here as character
arcs and storylines begin to converge
homelander shows up to battle soulja boy
and openly expresses fear for the first
time starlight publicly quits the seven
and shows true bravery by attempting to
stand up to soldier boy she live streams
a video where she calls out most supes
for only caring about themselves we're
looking at a new starlight and she is
fierce pieces continue to fall into
place for a final showdown between the
good and bad guys
any glimmer of hope we held for the
redemption of a train gets knocked to
the curb in the boys season 3 unable to
run due to his addiction to compound v
which causes heart issues the fastest
superhero decides to rebrand himself a
train commandeers his race to promote a
self-serving and tone-deaf brand of
energy drink turbo in a mockery of the
infamous 2017 kendall jenner pepsi
commercial a train stars in an ad where
protesters and police unite to gulp down
his new soda when a train decides to
confront a c-list vaught-soup named blue
hawk for his racist petroleum of new
jersey a tragedy ensues that leaves his
brother nathan paralyzed from the waist
down a train manipulates the events of
the tragedy to serve himself and when
given a chance to do the right thing he
fails although he suffers constant abuse
at the hands of homelander and the deep
a train continues to seek their approval
and betrays others to get back into
homelanders good graces a train thinks
he cares about others but focuses on
what will benefit him alone
if season 2 of the boys brought us
relationship goals to aspire to through
frenchine kamiko and season 3 solidifies
the depth and authenticity of their
romance the love that frenchie and
kimiko share grows as they become more
vulnerable with each other although
kimiko still can't speak the first
episode of season 3 showcases her
singing voice as the former weapon of
the shining light liberation army belts
out dream a little dream music provides
a healing outlet for kimiko she and
frenchie often snuggle up to watch old
musicals and the two were showcased in a
phenomenal musical dance number kimiko
realizes she blamed compound v for
making her a monster but in reality it's
her lifelong conditioning by the shining
light liberation army and personal
choices that caused her to become a
killing machine in the season finale
kimiko tells a downtrodden frenchie that
their past doesn't define them she
thought she would always be broken but
that frenchie saw something in her and
she sees it in him
in season two of the boys billy butcher
does everything within his power to
protect his ex-wife becca and her young
son ryan butcher from homelander when he
finally unlocks his powers at the end of
season 2 ryan shows his first signs of
superpowers with a tragic ending after
that devastating event butcher stows
ryan away with xcia deputy director
grace mallory however homelander finally
finds them and tells his son that he
loves him unconditionally the leader of
the 7 even means it as much as
homelander can love someone other than
himself ryan has long to hear those
words from butcher but homelander will
suffice ted
i want to go
ryan's loyalty to his dad grows in the
final episode of the boys season 3. he
sees butcher and his friends as the
enemy after the showdown with soldier
boy ryan leaves with homelander and his
psychotic grin in the last scene of the
season finale does not bode well for his
future
the last action-packed scene of the boys
season 3 takes place in vaught tower the
home of the seventh everything has led
to this showdown and it's epic soldier
boy gets the edge on homelander but when
ryan intercedes he turns his sights on
the boy butcher will still do anything
to protect ryan and can't let soldier
boy hurt him for a singular moment
butcher and homelander join forces
against the mega superhero ultimately
though it's maeve who sacrifices herself
in the fight homelander and ryan fly
away but there is little closure in the
aftermath of the battle both villainous
soups survive the showdown leaving
future story lines wide open the boy
still feels as timely and politically
resonant as ever the ending of season
three sets up the possibility for
another season but we'll just have to
tune in to bot news network to find out
what comes next
it's definitely gonna go
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the boys are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you